Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. Where does history start and end? Are the 1990s too recent to count as history? Well, this is our podcast, so we make the rules. Welcome to The Rest Is History, the podcast that refuses to be bound by convention. And today we're looking back at the decade that gave us Oasis and Blur, Boris Yeltsin, the death of Yugoslavia, Monica Lewinsky and Mr Blobby. Tom Holland, do you remember the 1990s? I mean, you must have been, what, 40, 45?
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。若想获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。您好，欢迎来到《历史其余部分》。历史从哪里开始，又在哪里结束？20世纪90年代距离现在太近，还不能算作历史吗？好吧，这是我们的播客，所以规矩由我们定。欢迎收听《历史其余部分》，这是一档拒绝被传统束缚的播客。今天，我们将回顾那个为我们带来绿洲乐队（Oasis）和布勒乐队（Blur）、鲍里斯·叶利钦、南斯拉夫解体、莫妮卡·莱温斯基以及“布洛比先生”（Mr Blobby）的十年。汤姆·霍兰，你还记得20世纪90年代吗？我的意思是，当时你一定，额，40岁还是45岁？
The banter keeps playing. I was in my 20s in the 1990s so i remember bits of it yeah and i think the best way to get into this dominic since uh yes this is very much your field um is to uh is to start with a tweet from thomas jones who asked who says my history teacher said that 50 years ago is history anything less is politics whatever the number there must be a cut off and that's exciting because it might suggest that actually yeah my career is over you're not legitimate your entire career is over well i mean a lot of people have been saying that for years to be fair but i want to leave that that exciting possibility hanging because before we come to the 90s and that question um just a quick
玩笑还在继续。90年代我才20多岁，所以我还记得一些片段，是的。我觉得切入这个话题最好的方式，多米尼克，鉴于——是的，这绝对是你的专业领域——那就是，额，从托马斯·琼斯（Thomas Jones）的一条推文开始，他问、或者说我的历史老师说过，50年前的叫历史，不到这个时间的叫政治。不管数字是多少，总得有个分界线，这很令人兴奋，因为这可能暗示着，实际上，是的，我的职业生涯结束了。你不够正统，你的整个职业生涯都结束了。好吧，我的意思是，公平地说，多年来很多人一直在这么说。不过我想把这个令人兴奋的假设先悬置起来，因为在我们谈到90年代和那个问题之前，额，只是简单地
reprise to our last episode which was uh we gave our list of top 10 weird wars and we've had quite um quite a response to that um we have yeah giving giving us um some suggestions uh so we have uh three from steven clark so we have the flagstaff war a scrap about a flagpole in which the maori beat the british empire i assume you know all about that, Dominic. I know nothing about that. But you must know about the football war. This is Stephen's second suggestion. Yeah. So I didn't, a lot of people said to us,
回顾一下我们上一期节目。我们列出了十大离奇战争的名单，对此我们得到了相当热烈的反响，我们确实收到了很多建议。斯蒂芬·克拉克（Stephen Clark）给我们提出了三个。首先是旗杆战争（Flagstaff War），这是一场围绕旗杆的冲突，毛利人击败了大英帝国。我想你对这个很了解吧，多米尼克？我对这个一无所知。但你一定知道足球战争（Football War）。这是斯蒂芬的第二个建议。是的。所以，我不知道，很多人对我们说，
why didn't you pick the football war? El Salvador and Honduras fighting in 1969 after a World Cup qualifier. I mean, I think it's A, quite well known, and we had quite a lot of South American, sort of Latin American wars. But it is a good, weird war. If you're going to do weird wars, the Football War is a good one. What's Clarke's third one? The Star Wars. So that's not the film's, it's a series of main conflicts between 562 and 781. You must know that. Yeah,
你们为什么不选足球战争？萨尔瓦多和洪都拉斯在1969年世界盃预选赛后爆发的战争。我的意思是，我觉得它A，相当知名，而且我们已经有很多南美洲、拉丁美洲那边的战争了。但这是一场精彩的离奇战争。如果要讲离奇战争，足球战争算是一个不错的选择。克拉克的第三个是什么？星际战争（Star Wars）。所以这不是指电影，这是指562年到781年之间的一系列主要冲突。你一定知道这个。对，
you know that really well, do you Tom? That's your period. Right in the back of my hand. Again, I've never heard of that. um we got one from dave waters who offers this priceless suggestion the war of the stray dog in 1925 caused by the shooting of a border guard chasing a stray dog greece bulgaria lasted 11 days and then he has a great podcast as per usual so we very much like that suggestion uh jim ju has an even shorter one the anglo zanzibar war he says too short to make the list is it still a war if hostilities lasted the length of half a football match before stoppage time so yes this was a war that lasted about 45 minutes and i think um the british wanted to get rid of the ruler of zanzibar i can't remember the exact details but basically
你对这个了如指掌吧，汤姆？那是你的研究时期。了如指掌。同样，我从未听说过这个。额，我们收到了戴夫·沃特斯（Dave Waters）发来的一条消息，他提出了这个无价的建议：1925年的流浪狗战争（War of the Stray Dog），起因是追捕流浪狗的边防警卫被枪杀，希腊和保加利亚之间的战争，持续了11天。然后他像往常一样制作了一个很棒的播客，所以我们非常喜欢这个建议。额，吉姆·朱（Jim Ju）提出了一个更短的：英桑战争（Anglo-Zanzibar War）。他说，时间太短，进不了名单。如果敌对状态持续的时间只相当于半场足球赛加伤停补时，这还能算是一场战争吗？所以是的，这是一场只持续了大约45分钟的战争。我想，额，英国人想要赶走桑津的统治者，我记不清具体细节了，但基本上，
yes it lasted less than a half of football and And I think British one sailor was injured. And we won, as we often won these sort of gunboat diplomacy dust-ups. Back in those days, yeah. And then we've got two Irish ones. We've got one from Dominic. No, I am Dominic. Yeah. I'm not sending – I should start doing that, actually,
是的，它持续的时间甚至不到半场足球赛。而且我认为英国有一名水兵受伤。我们赢了，就像我们过去经常赢得这种炮舰外交的小冲突一样。在那些日子里，是的。然后我们有两个关于爱尔兰的。我们有一个来自多米尼克的……不，我就是多米尼克。是的。我没有发——其实我应该开始这么做了，
start sending questions to our podcast. Yes, a Dominic sandbrook has written in with a ludicrous question what nonsense is this it's not you dominic it's ian winterton who drew our attention to uh the 1866 irish invasion of canada i don't know anything about that i'm going to look that one up um and emin mcginty the Battle of Cwlldremni, I hope I pronounced that right, in around 555 AD in Ireland was started over a prayer book. St Finian and St Columba began the war after both claimed ownership of the Psalter. I mean, that's an excellent reason. There was a famous prayer book war, wasn't there, in Scotland? 1638, 1640 or whatever it is,
开始向我们的播客发送问题。是的，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）发来了一个荒谬的问题：这算什么胡说八道？不是你，多米尼克，是伊恩·温特顿（Ian Winterton）提请我们注意，额，1866年爱尔兰入侵加拿大事件。我对这个一无所知，我得去查查。还有埃敏·麦金蒂（Emin McGinty）提到的库尔德雷姆尼战役（Battle of Cwlldremni），希望我发音准确，大约在公元555年发生在爱尔兰，起因是一本祈祷书。圣菲尼安（St Finian）和圣科伦巴（St Columba）因为都声称对《诗篇》（Psalter）拥有所有权而挑起了这场战争。我的意思是，这是一个极好的理由。苏格兰不是也有一场著名的祈祷书战争吗？1638年、1640年什么的，
prayer book war then. And there's one from Sparkling Wine Charlie. He says he's slightly disappointed, well, she's slightly disappointed, that the Turbot War wasn't mentioned. Tom, I know you know all about the Turbot War. It's not Cod Wars, is it? No, I don't know what it is. You don't know either.
那是一场祈祷书战争。还有一位名叫“起泡酒查理”（Sparkling Wine Charlie）的听众。他说他有点失望，或者说她有点失望，因为没有提到多宝鱼战争（Turbot War）。汤姆，我知道你对多宝鱼战争了如指掌。这不是鳕鱼战争（Cod Wars），对吧？不，我不知道那是什么。你也不知道。
I know about the Cod Wars, but I, I mean, we lost the Cod Wars, so I've kind of tried to blank it out, but the turbo war is a mystery to me. So basically if anyone listened to this podcast for the first time, which it's a session of tweets in which we show that we know nothing at all about anything. So not promising. I think, I think that we should cut to the chase and go back to something that you at
我知道鳕鱼战争，但我的意思是，我们输掉了鳕鱼战争，所以我基本上试着把它从记忆里抹去，但多宝鱼战争对我来说是个谜。所以基本上，如果有人是第一次听这个播客，这就是一连串的推文，在推文中我们表现得对任何事情都一无所知。所以听起来不太妙。我觉得，我觉得我们应该直奔主题，回到……
any rate do know about which is um uh how you write contemporary history yeah so the 90s just yeah yeah so just to remind we're talking about the 90s and this tweet from thomas jones um the history teacher who says that 50 years ago's history anything less is politics are you a fraud dominic sandbrook well we talked about mr blobby the in the So Mr. Blobby definitely isn't politics. You always get this when you're doing quite recent history. People say, is it really history? I mean, I got this when I started my sort of series about post-war Britain, writing about the 50s. And people would say, oh, the 50s, how in the 60s, how can that be history?
无论如何你确实了解的内容，也就是，额，你如何撰写当代史。是的，所以90年代，刚好……是的，是的，所以提醒一下，我们在谈论90年代，以及托马斯·琼斯的这条推文——那位历史老师说，50年前的叫历史，不到这个时间的叫政治。你是个骗子吗，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克？好吧，我们刚才谈到了布洛比先生，在……所以布洛比先生绝对不是政治。当你研究相当近期的历史时，总会遇到这种情况。人们会说，这真的是历史吗？我的意思是，当我开始写关于战后英国的系列文章、撰写50年代的历史时，我就遇到了这种情况。人们会说，哦，50年代，怎么——60年代，怎么能算是历史呢？
AJP Taylor wrote his history of britain between the wars which he called english history great title so he published that in 1965 and he was right going up to the end of the second world war so you're talking and that was in the oxford history of england i think so that's sort of 20 year gap and 20 to 30 years is i would say probably the norm it's the point at which people start looking back so when litton straight he wrote his eminent victorians what's that 1920s so again about 20 to 30 years after i think you then get a bit of a sense of perspective most of the actors have left the stage um it feels like the day before yesterday. And so there's a sense of looking back rather than looking around. I don't know, what do you think? I mean, all this must be utter
A·J·P·泰勒（AJP Taylor）写过他的《两次世界大战之间的英国历史》（English History 1914–1945），他将其命名为《英国历史》，这个书名真棒。所以他在1965年出版了这本书，他写到了第二次世界大战结束。所以你在谈论——那好像是收录在《牛津英国史》里的，我想。所以大约有20年的时间差，20到30年，我想这大概是常态。这是人们开始回首往事的节点。所以当利顿·斯特拉切（Lytton Strachey）写他的《维多利亚女王时代名人传》（Eminent Victorians）时，那是什么时候？20世纪20年代？所以同样是在事件发生大约20到30年之后。我想你那时会产生一种历史视角，大多数当事人已经退出了历史舞台，
nonsense to you as somebody who writes about the Romans and stuff. No, not at all. Because to the Romans and to the Greeks, essentially, only people who had lived through the events that they were describing were qualified to be historians. So Thucydides is the classic example of that, that he was a general in the Peloponnesian War. So he felt that that was very much what qualified him to write about it. And basically, if you were writing about anything that you hadn't lived through, you were a bit of a fraud. So what about Plutarch or somebody? Surely he's writing about... Yeah, he's not really rated. Right, okay.
感觉就像发生在昨天一样。因此，这是一种回顾而不是环顾的感觉。我不知道，你怎么看？我的意思是，作为一个研究罗马人及类似内容的人，这一切对你来说一定都是纯粹的胡说八道。不，一点也不。因为对于罗马人和希腊人来说，本质上，只有那些亲身经历过他们所描述事件的人才有资格成为历史学家。因此，修昔底德（Thucydides）就是其中的经典例子，他是伯罗奔尼撒战争中的一名将军。所以他觉得这正是他有资格撰写这段历史的原因。基本上，如果你在写任何你没有亲自经历过的事情，你多多少乎算是个骗子。那么普鲁塔克（Plutarch）或其他人呢？他写的肯定……是的，他并没有受到太高评价。好吧，原来是这样。
I mean, he's writing his biograph's he's he's not really rated he's right okay i mean he's writing his biographies and things yeah to be cutting edge it's essentially history for the for the greeks and the romans was what you do is contemporary history so you are absolutely the co-evil with lucidities as i've always maintained yeah but but i i mean what i've noticed with with your books but you begin in the 50s and you've gone right the way up to 1983 was the last, 1982 really, isn't it? Yeah, it's two. It's the last one. Is that the space of time that are covered in your books get shorter and shorter.
我的意思是，他写的是他的传记之类的。是的，要成为前沿学者，本质上，对于希腊人和罗马人来说，历史就是你所做的事情，也就是当代史。所以你绝对是与修昔底德同时代的人，正如我一直坚持的那样。是的。但是，我的意思是，我在你的书里注意到的是，你从50年代开始写起，一直写到了1983年作为最后一本，其实是1982年，对吧？是的，是第二本。这是最后一本。你书中涵盖的时间跨度是不是越来越短了？
Yeah, I know. It's ridiculous. So it's almost like the closer you get, the more there is to write about. Is that the feeling? Is that how you? No, I think actually what it's almost like the closer you get, the more there is to write about. Is that the feeling? Is that how you? No, I think actually what it is, is the closer you get there, if I can be sort of self-flagellating for a moment, I think the closer you get, the harder it is to get a perspective about what matters. But also the temptation becomes greater to just immerse yourself in detail
是的，我懂。这太荒谬了。所以这几乎就像是，你离得越近，要写的东西就越多。是这种感觉吗？你是这么觉得的吗？不，其实我觉得情况是这样的，离得越近——如果我可以稍微进行一下自我鞭挞的话——我认为你离得越近，就越难对什么才是重要的事物保持一种视角。而且，仅仅沉浸在读者能够认出的细节中的诱惑也变得更大了。
that the reader will recognise. So, you know, imagine writing the same sort of books about the Victorian age. I mean, most of it would just be meaningless to readers. They'd say this is a lot of sort of trivial and insignificant fluff. You know, what was on at the music halls, the big debate about some celebrities that we've never heard of. I think you can get away with that with very recent history because so many people pick up on all the references. You know, the sort of stuff in my last book,
所以，你可以想象一下，如果写一本关于维多利亚时代的同类书籍。我的意思是，其中大部分内容对现代读者来说都毫无意义。他们会觉得这是一堆琐碎且无关紧要的废话。你知道，音乐厅里在演什么，围绕着某个我们从未听说过的名人的大辩论。我认为你在写非常近期的历史时可以侥幸过关，因为有太多人能捕捉到所有的典故。你知道，我上一本书里的那些内容，
which was about the early 80s, the references to, you know, I don't know, sitcoms or to cricket matches or to, you know, football hooliganism outbreaks or whatever. Those mean something to readers now in a way that they will be utterly meaningless in the 25th century and nobody will care right so it's interesting for me reading um your most recent one which is about the kind of the first
这本书是关于80年代初的，里面对……我不知道，情景喜剧、板球比赛或者足球流氓骚乱事件等等的提及。这些对于现在的读者来说是有意义的，但在25世纪，它们将变得毫无意义，也没有人会在乎。对，所以对于我来说，阅读你最近的那本书是一件很有趣的事，这本书是关于……政府的。我有点模模糊糊地记得政治的大致轮廓，因为我当时是——1981年我13岁，所以我当时开始阅读报纸、观看新闻了。但你书中整章节地提到了新浪漫主义（New Romantics）和《流行音乐排行榜》（Smash Hits），当然，绝对的，我都记得这一切，还有情景喜剧等等，所以它非常新鲜。但如果我们回到我们原本应该讨论的话题：90年代。其中一个问题肯定在于，通过这种方式进行报道，因为你算是亲身经历了那个时代，所以很容易让人以为你的经历在某种程度上具有普遍性。但事实并非如此，对吧？而且你的视角在某种程度上具有特权，因为你亲历过，因此你对它感觉更清新。但或许在某种意义上，它成了一种阻碍。
government was that i kind of vaguely remembered the the broad outlines of the politics because i was i was um what was i was 13 in 1981 so I was kind of starting to read newspapers and watch the news but but you have whole sections on neuromantics and smash hits and so of course absolutely I remember all that and the sitcoms and stuff so it was very fresh but if we go back to the the topic we're meant to be covering. The 90s. One of the issues surely must be with covering like that is that because you've kind of lived through it, the temptation is to assume that your experiences are somehow universal. And they're not, are they? And your perspective somehow is privileged because you've lived through it, so therefore you feel fresher to it. But perhaps in
我真的觉得这完全是一种阻碍，汤姆。我经常发现这一点，当我在做关于当代史的讲座时，人们会说，好吧，其实我当时就在场，我知道70年代并不全都是阴暗的，它们其实非常美妙。然后观众席上又会有另一个人插话，说我在70年代为英国利兰公司（British Leyland）工作过，那简直糟糕透顶。
a sense, it becomes an impediment. I think it's a total impediment, actually, Tom. I think I notice this all the time giving talks about contemporary history is that people will say, well, actually I was there, and I know that the 70s were not all grim, that they were wonderful. And then there'll be somebody else in the audience who will then pipe up and say, I worked for British Leyland in the 70s and it was bloody awful.
基本上，他们只是在争论，挥舞着各自的个人经历，并认为那就是常态。我认为这绝对正确。我觉得90年代很有趣，因为我认为我们对90年代的记忆并不像对80年代、或者说60和70年代那样充满矛盾。
And basically they just have an argument where they're brandishing their own individual experience and assuming that that's the norm. And I think that's exactly right. I think the 90s is an interesting one because I think that our memories of the 90s are not very conflicted as they are of the 80s or indeed the 60s and 70s.
所以，由于这是一个经济稳定、经济增长的时期，冷战已经结束，90年代有一种“感觉良好”（feel-good）的氛围。所以我想，如果你找100个人问他们对90年代的记忆，无论是在英国还是可能在美国，他们都会讲述一个相对相似的故事，你不觉得吗？我不认为我们会争论90年代的意义。所以我当时在90年代正值20多岁，在20多岁的年纪经历那个时代真是太棒了，因为有很多好玩的事情可以做。因此，比如说摇头丸（ecstasy）、英伦摇滚（Britpop）和这一切在我的记忆中占据了极其显眼的位置。所以当我回想起90年代时，那往往就是我想到的东西。
So because it was a time of you know economic stability economic growth because there was the end cold war had ended was there was a sort of feel-good factor in the 90s so i guess if you got a hundred people and asked them you know their memories of the 90s certainly in britain and probably in america as well um they would tell a relatively similar story don't you think i think we don't argue about the meaning of the 90s so i was in my in my 20s during the 90s and it was a great time to be in your 20s because there were lots of enjoyable things to do um and and so you know ecstasy and brit pop and everything has a massively salient place in my memories and so therefore when i think about the 90s that's tends to be what what i think about
你想到了摇头丸，那可不是人们心目中的汤姆·霍兰……我想到的是所有那些好玩的事情，对吧？你在90年代刚满20岁，我就不多说了。但它确实是……你知道的，它很有趣。所以这主要就是，如果我对过去有一种联觉（synesthetic）感觉的话，我认为80年代有点灰暗、阴郁和可怕，而我认为90年代是……你知道的，巨大的笑脸表情、阳光、麦田怪圈，简直太棒了。但当然，你知道，这准确吗？
you think about ecstasy that's not the tom holland that people uh i i think about all the fun things there were to do right you were in your early 20s in the 90s i will go no further but it was it was you know it was it was fun so that's chiefly you know if i had a kind of synesthetic sense of the past i think of the 80s as kind of slightly gray and grim and dire and i think of the 90s as you know big smiley yeah big smiley icon and sun and you know crop circles and just great um but of course you know that's is that accurate um well i think we forget that certainly in britain the 1990s you can divide into the sort of there are two governments aren't they the major governments and then the black government the major government was exceedingly unpopular for most of its tenure um there was a
好吧，我认为我们忘记了，当然在英国，20世纪90年代可以分为——有两届不同的政府，对吧？梅杰政府（Major government）和布莱尔政府。梅杰政府在其任期的大部分时间里都极不受欢迎，有一种乌烟瘴气、无能等等的感觉。事实上，我认为发生的事情是，正如这些事情经常发生的那样，90年代被某个特定的时刻接管了。我们对20世纪90年代的记忆被一个特定的时刻所着色，那就是大约1996到1997年。对许多人来说，有趣的是在推特上，很多人提到了1996年欧洲杯、托尼·布莱尔的登台以及“酷不列颠”（Cool Britannia）。这种印象已经渗透出来，成为了整个十年代的代名词，至少在英国是这样。我想现在人们回首往事——有趣的是，各个时期的意义是如何改变的，因为现在，
sense of sleaze and incompetence and whatnot. And I think actually what's happened is the 90s, as these things as often happen, the 90s have been taken over by a particular moment. Our memory of the 1990s is coloured by a particular moment, which is sort of 1996-97. For lots of people, it's interesting in the tweets, a lot of people mention Euro 96 and the coming of Tony Blair and Cool Britannia. And that has sort of seeped out and become the meaning of the whole decade, certainly in Britain. And I think now people look back. I mean, it's interesting how sort of meanings of periods sort of change, because now
当人们谈论20世纪90年代时，我认为有两种谈论方式：一种是失去的黄金时代——泡沫破裂前、新冠疫情前、民粹主义和特朗普出现前等等；或者他们认为那是事情开始出错的时刻，当时我们自满、傲慢，为后来所有的灾难埋下了祸根。你不觉得吗？我认为人们就是以这两种方式看待它的。我觉得……这很有趣，因为年代从来不完全与——不与具体的数字完全吻合，对吧？所以80年代始于1979年，如果你是英国人的话，始于79年，并随着撒切尔下台或冷战结束而结束。所以80年代确实作为一个时期发挥了作用。我认为90年代始于柏林墙倒塌，是的，所以始于1989年，我认为它结束于2001年9月11日。是的，我赞同这一点。我认为人们的记忆是，
when people talk about the 1990s, I think there are two ways they talk about it one is lost golden age pre-crash pre-covid pre-populism and trump and blah blah um or they see it as that's the moment where everything went wrong where we were complacent and hubristic and we sowed the seeds of all these sort of disasters to come don't you think i think those are the two ways that people i think i mean i it's interesting because decades never exactly map onto the no the precise numbers do they um so so the 80s begin in 1979 if you're british begin in 79 and and end um with with the fall of thatcher or the end of the cold war i mean so the 80s do work as a as a moment the the 90s i think begin with the fall of the cult of the berlin war yeah so begin in 1989 and i think that they end in on 9 11 2001 yeah i'd buy that and i think that the memory is that
这是一个你不会被核战争阴影所困扰，也不会被恐怖主义阴影以及反恐战争等诸如此类的事情所困扰的时期。所以你回看——对我来说，我把它看作是一个黄金青春期。是的。但当然，那会被你自己的青春所涂抹，对吧？绝对的，绝对的。所以这对我来说将是一个问题，我想，如果我试图去写它，因为我认为那种感觉会彻底给它着色。但你的超凡才华，我的意思是，总是能够敏锐捕捉到社会内部与某个十年或时期的刻板印象相左的对立趋势。所以，你知道，持逆向思维，对90年代持逆向思维：它很糟糕，诸如此类。如果你要从全球视角来看待20世纪90年代，你知道，持逆向思维，对90年代持逆向思维：它很糟糕，无论如何。如果你要对20世纪90年代持全球视角，你很容易就能讲出一个极其黯淡的故事。所以这是卢旺达的十年。这是南斯拉夫解体的十年，我认为这对我们这一代人来说实际上是一个非常深刻且清醒的教训。所以你看到一个欧洲国家四分五裂。我的意思是，我们在本系列早期做过一期关于内战的播客。对我来说，那始终是我所想到的内战——一个我在童年时视为理所当然的国家（托维尔和迪恩曾在那里赢得金牌），在90年代四分五裂。还有，我认为，俄罗斯发生了一个巨大的地缘政治故事，我们在西方并没有给予它应有的重视。因此，苏联解体以及一个国家、一个大国、世界体系的一个真正核心陷入崩溃，你知道，俄罗斯男性的平均寿命在20世纪90年代初缩短了近10年，经济完全陷入崩溃。所以你可以讲述一个关于90年代的相当黯淡的故事。你也可以讲述——我的意思是，回到自满这一点上，你可以争辩说，90年代最具决定性的书，在某些方面，是弗朗西斯·福山（Francis Fukuyama）的《历史的终结与最后的人》（The End of History and the Last Man），它可能被不公正地视为冷战胜利主义的一股狂潮。你知道，我们赢了，自由民主是未来的潮流，而作为体制冲突和意识形态冲突的历史即将画上句号。它结束了。我的意思是，这真的有点歪曲了他的论点。但这似乎捕捉到了90年代的一些自满情绪。你认为90年代是一个自满的时期吗？
this is a period where you're not haunted by the shadow of nuclear war and you're not haunted by the shadow of terrorism and wars on terror and all that kind of stuff. And so you look and so for me, I look back on it as a kind of period of golden youth. Yes. But of course, that's then coloured by your own youth, isn't it? Absolutely. Absolutely. So then that would be a problem for me, I think, if I was trying to write about it, because I think that that sense would completely colour it. But your great talent, I mean, is always to pick up on the countervailing trends within society that go against the kind of the stereotype of a decade or a period. So, you know, be contrarian, be contrarian about the 90s. It was terrible,
好吧，我以前谈过这个，但我记得在1989年夏天去巴黎参加法国大革命两百周年纪念活动。当时有一场盛大的游行。
whatever. If you were going to take a worldwide view of the 1990s, you know, be contrarian, be contrarian about the 90s. It was terrible, whatever. If you were going to take a worldwide view of the 1990s, you could easily tell an incredibly bleak story. So it's the decade of Rwanda. It's the decade of the death of Yugoslavia, which I think actually for people of our generation was a very salutary and sobering tale. So you had a European country tearing itself apart. I mean, we did a podcast very early on in this series about civil wars. And that, for me, is always the civil war that I think of, you know, a country that I had taken for granted as a child, you know, Torval and Dean had won their gold medal there, ripping itself apart in the 1990s. And also, I think, a massive geopolitical story in Russia, which we don't think about as much as we should in the West. So the end of the Soviet Union, and a country, a power, a really sort of a linchpin of the world
游行的开场是骑着自行车的中国异见人士穿过巴黎街头，在天安门广场事件背景的衬托下做着紧握拳头的动作。回想起来，这可能是最具标志性的事件，这种感觉实际上——你知道，远比俄罗斯、甚至美国或其他任何地方发生的事情重要得多，那就是中国发生的事情。而我当时并没有真正警觉到这一点。
system going into meltdown, you know, Russian men, their life expectancy dropped by the best part of 10 years, in the early years of the 1990s, you know, an economy in complete meltdown. So you could tell quite a bleak story about the 90s. And you could also tell us, you know, an economy in complete meltdown. So you could tell quite a bleak story about the 90s. And you could also tell us, I mean, going back to the hubris point, you could argue that the defining book of the 90s, in some ways, is Francis Fukuyama's The End of History, which perhaps unfairly has been seen as this sort of blast of Cold War triumphalism. You know, we've won liberal democracies, the wave of the future, and the history as the clash of systems and as a clash of ideologies
我当时并没有真正警觉到这一点。这比伊斯兰世界与西方世界之间表面上的紧张关系要重要得多，这种紧张关系在90年代也很明显在酝酿中。本·拉登大约在那时开始崭露头角。但实际上，是中国，对吧？我想另一件事，另一件事当然是，我也清楚地记得它的开始：我在牛津，我未来的妻子在斯坦福呆了一年，所以你知道，那是写信带来的巨大精神创伤，写信太搞笑了。有一个美国朋友，他有一个小小的……早期Mac电脑之一，他跟我谈起了这个叫电子邮件的东西。我记得在他的小Mac上发出了我的第一封电子邮件。然后逐渐在整个十年里，互联网变得越来越……他是90年代的核心人物，他曾在中情局工作过，后来来到牛津，拿到了学位，并非常积极地参与制作麦田怪圈。所以我唯一的一个麦田怪圈就是和他一起做的，那真是一件很棒的事。无论如何，他当时和我们住在一起，他帮我们设置了我们的第一个互联网连接。
is going to come to a halt. It's over. I mean, that's to really bastardize his argument. But that seemed to capture some of the sort of complacency of the 90s. Do you think it's a complacent period, the 90s? Well, I've talked about this before, but I remember going to Paris for the bicentennial of the French Revolution in 1989, summer of 1989. And there was this great kind of parade.
我记得他打入的第一句话是“拉拉队长”（cheerleader）。噢，天哪。那是我们查阅的第一个东西。这一切都太“90年代”了。但在这种背景下，我也记得我的很多阅读都是关于威廉·吉布森（William Gibson）以及所有这些内容的，事情的发展方式早就被预言过了。是的，当时确实有一种真正的技术变革感，对吧？文化变革。我的意思是，我的经历基本上完全一样。
And the opening sequence of it were Chinese dissidents on bicycles cycling through the streets of Paris, kind of making clenched fist signs against the backdrop of what had happened at Tiananmen Square. And I guess looking back, that's probably the most significant event, is the sense that actually what, you know, far more important really than what's happening in Russia or indeed in America or anything is what's happening in China. And I wasn't really alert to that.
我有一个美国朋友，他来自斯坦福，作为交换生在这里待一年，他带了一个装在盒子里的电脑，这让我大吃一惊。那是我见过的第一台笔记本电脑。他打开这个设备说，当今年年底我回斯坦福时，我们可以互相发信息。我说，那——那只是一种晦涩的变态行为，我才不去学校的机房，一个人坐在黑暗中敲击信息呢。你知道的，我每三年给你写一次信，如果幸运的话。但它确实来了，我认为这是一个非常具体的时刻，比如说1995年到1997年，人们从没有电子邮件地址转变为拥有电子邮件并连接互联网。显然，当人们撰写20世纪90年代的历史时，他们显然会关注冷战的结束、
I wasn't really alert to that. Much more important than the seeming tensions between Islam and the Western world, which was also clearly brewing in the 90s. Bin Laden is starting to kind of surface around that time. But really, it's China, isn't it? And I suppose the other thing, the other thing, of course, that also I remember absolutely beginning, I was at oxford and uh my wife-to-be was um away for a year at stanford so you know deep trauma writing letters hilarious writing letters yeah and there was an american friend who had a kind of little um one of those early um maps yeah um and he told me about this thing called email. And I remember sending my first email on his little Mac. And then gradually over the course of the decade, the Internet became more and more of a sequence. central 90s guy he was he'd been in um he'd been in the cia he'd come over to oxford he'd uh done a degree he'd become very involved in making corn circles so i made my only corn circle with him uh that was a kind of that was a great thing anyway he was staying with us and and he helped
中国的对外开放、俄罗斯发生的事情，可能还有冷战的结束、中国的对外开放、俄罗斯发生的事情，大概还有欧盟的发展。但实际上，我认为压倒所有这些事情的是一件像印刷术一样伟大的事情，那就是数字经济和数字文化的发展。前几天我查看了我的亚马逊账户，
us to set up our first internet connection um and i remember the first thing he typed in was cheerleader. Oh, God. That was the very first thing that we ever looked up on. And that's all so kind of 90s. But against the back, I also remember a lot of my reading was in kind of William Gibson and all that kind of stuff. And the way that what was happening had been prophesied. Yeah, there was a real sense, I think, of technological change, wasn't there, cultural change. I mean, I have basically exactly the same story.
寻找我的第一笔订单。那是1999年。我在1999年在亚马逊上为家人买了一些圣诞礼物。我想，天哪，从那时起我给杰夫·贝佐斯（Jeff Bezos）送了多少钱啊？显然，这是一个90年代的故事，它产生了不可估量的影响，远远大于任何英国大选结果或诸如此类的任何事情。是的，所以在某种程度上，90年代作为80年代的阴暗与2001年之后一切事物的阴暗之间的“防火墙”的概念其实是一种错觉，你会这么认为吗？实际上，它是20年代发生的好多变革的温床。事实上，你可以说，21世纪有什么真正的变化是没有在20世纪90年代就显现出来的吗？确实如此。这个说法很好。我想你可以在某种程度上认为，接下来的两个十年其实就是那些已经在进行中的力量的释放。我的意思是，如果你回到20世纪90年代中期，
I had an American friend who was on a years exchange from Stanford and he had a computer in a box, which amazed me. It was the first laptop I'd ever seen. He opened this device and he said, when I go back to stanford at the end of the year we can send each other messages and i said that's that's just that's just some sort of obscure perversion i'm not going to go to the college computer room and sit on my own in the dark typing in messages you know i'll write you a letter once every three years maybe
你会发现英国政治被关于欧洲的争论所主导。你知道，美国人在争论总统弹劾案和文化战争。我的意思是，文化战争的概念是80年代末90年代初美国的事物，是对政治正确的反弹，共和党人对比尔·克林顿的恨意以及关于比尔·克林顿的阴谋论。所有这些事情都让人觉得，那个时候发生的事情与现在发生的事情之间有着真正的共鸣。显然还有俄罗斯、中国、不断崛起的伊斯兰教与西方世界。我的意思是，所有这些东西在雏形中都已经在那里了。对。当然，90年代发生的一件著名的事情是，围绕谁将成为第一名展开了巨大的争端：绿洲乐队还是布勒乐队。这就是那件……这可是大事。这可是重磅内容。但以多米尼克·桑德布鲁克的视角来看，
if you're lucky but it, and it came very, I think it was a very specific moment, let's say 95 to 97, when people went from having no email address to being on email and having internet connections. And obviously that, when people write the history of the 1990s, obviously they'll look at the end of the Cold War,
这其实相当重要，不是吗？因为这是一个围绕着排行榜展开的国家级时刻。这是最后一个。这是最后一个，因为从那时起，排行榜、音乐流媒体和一切都变得如此碎片化，以至于围绕“哪支乐队将成为第一名”展开的国家级时刻的概念变得不可思议。因此，从某种意义上说，90年代不仅是一个开始，它也是自1955年左右以来一直存在的这种独特文化的终结。是的，集体国家文化的消亡。
they'll look at the opening up of China, they'll look at what happened in Russia, probably the end of the Cold War. They'll look at the opening up of China. They'll look at what happened in Russia, probably the development of the EU. But I think actually dwarfing all those things is something as big as the printing press, which is the development of this digital economy and this digital culture. I had a look the other day at my Amazon account
这是一个故事，不仅仅是英国的故事，你还会看到这个故事在世界各地的社会中上演，对吧？所以绿洲乐队与布勒乐队的这场对决，实际上是有意重现披头士乐队对阵滚石乐队，不是吗？是的，而且这一切非常后现代。它本身就是，是的，绝对的。这完全是有意的，并且带有不同层面的讽刺和自我认知。但现在感觉起来就像是，你知道，这在2005年是不可能发生的，
to look for my first purchase. So that was 1999. I bought some of my Christmas presents for my family on Amazon in 1999. And I thought, God, how much money have I given to Jeff Bezos since then? And obviously that's a 1990s story that has had incalculable, far greater effect than any British general election result or anything of that kind. Yeah, so in a sense actually the idea of the 90s as a kind of firebreak between the grimness of the 80s and then the grimness of everything that follows on from 2001 is illusory then you would argue it's actually it's the seedbed for a lot of the changes
因为到那时，排行榜已经从国家显赫地位跌落了。它不再是故事的一部分了。我认为另一个时刻，对于英国听众来说是一个共同的国家时刻，每个人都会记得，那就是戴安娜王妃的去世。但也许我们应该先休息一下，然后再深入探讨那个话题，你知道，这是一个如此宏大的主题。是的，好的，好的。我们休息回来后再谈戴安娜之死。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、加更节目，
that have happened in the 20s and in fact could say, has anything really changed in the 21st century that wasn't implicit in the 1990s? That's true. That's a good way of putting it. I think you could argue in some ways, couldn't you, that the following two decades were the playing out of forces that were already underway. I mean, if you went back to the mid-1990s,
以及优先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。提醒一下，我们在封城期间实行双班制，所以每周两期节目。在周四，我们将推出一个更具诱惑力的节目，汤姆和我将与哈莉·鲁本霍尔德（Hallie Rubenhold）一起讨论18和19世纪的性。那一期绝对不适合在工作时间收听，至少我希望如此。现在，既然汤姆已经擦掉了眼镜上的蒸汽，我们可以回到20世纪90年代了。
you'd find British politics dominated by arguments about Europe. You know, Americans were arguing about impeachment of a president and culture war. I mean, the idea of culture wars is a late 80s, early 90s American thing, the backlash against political correctness, sort of the Republicans' hatred of Bill Clinton and kind of conspiracy theories about Bill Clinton. I mean, all those things feel like there's a real resonance
所以，汤姆，我们刚才要谈论戴安娜的去世。你还记得戴安娜去世的……这是那些你记得自己身在何处、正在做什么的时刻之一，对吧？我记得。我记得非常清楚，因为我们当时正在搬家。对。我们想要一些欢快的音乐来，你知道的，在我们搬椅子之类的东西时给我们提提神，结果狂风中到处都是沉闷的葬礼音乐。是的，整件事……是的，非常奇怪。你觉得那种事情——我的意思是，就像布勒乐队一样是一个共同的时刻，我想它可能确实是，但它会是一团团共同的经历，以至于……是的，我的意思是，想象一下推特上的反应，想象一下……是的，我的意思是，我认为戴安娜的去世就像是一个巨大的宣泄时刻。我的意思是，英国人擅长这种狄更斯式的伤感宣泄，不是吗？所以你有没有做过什么现在觉得尴尬的事？你知道吗？我当时其实在保加利亚。我在保加利亚背包旅行，我们青年旅社的一个人告诉我们说斯蒂纳王妃（Prince Stenner）去世了。我们在电视上看到了。然后，不可思议的是，我们在巴尔干山脉的一个小村庄里。
between what was happening then and what's happening now. And obviously Russia, Putin, China, rising Islam and the West. I mean, all those things are there in embryo, really. Right. One thing, of course, that famously happens in the 90s is this huge issue around who's going to become number one. Oasis or Blur. And this is the thing that... That's getting important. That's getting important stuff. But playing Dominic Sandbrook here,
村里的人都从家里搬出了这些木椅。他们都聚集在那个饱经风霜的共产主义时期老旧电视机前的中央广场上。他们都在看电视上的节目。而我们是背包客，所以我们没有。你知道，这是互联网出现之前的事。他们在看葬礼，他们在看埃尔顿·约翰、乔治·迈克尔、约翰·梅杰和托尼·布莱尔用英语讲话，这绝对是光怪陆离。我当时记得自己想，为什么？他们怎么会在乎这个？但他们确实在乎。所以这是一个国际事件，哦，在保加利亚的山区显然也是如此。是的，所以我认为确实如此。我想，显然，现在还会发生这种事吗？英国王室还有这种魅力吗？
it is actually quite significant, isn't it? Because it's a national moment that revolves around the charts. The last one. It's the last one, because from that point on, the charts and the streaming of music and everything, it all becomes so fragmented that the idea of a national moment around, you know, which band is going to be number one becomes inconceivable. So in a sense, the 90s is not just a beginning. It's also an end for that kind of distinctive culture that had existed since, what, 1955 or something? Yeah, the death of a collective national culture.
我的意思是，因为《王冠》（The Crown）这部剧，可能还有吧。也许吧。好吧，说到人们真正聚集在电视机前，我的意思是，这有多复古啊？P·奥康奈尔（P. O'Connell）的评论：我现在回想起自己在90年代的生活，他说，并认为如果当时能使用智能手机，情况就会完全不同了。所以这实际上延续了我们刚才谈论的话题——技术，是的，也许它是所有事物中最伟大的变革推动者。
And that's a story, not just a British story, but you see that story playing out in societies all over the world, don't you? So that Oasis Blur battle, which is actually a self-conscious attempt to replay the Beatles versus the Rolling Stones, isn't it? It is, and it's all very postmodern. It is itself, yeah, absolutely. It's completely self-conscious and there's a sort of there are levels of upon levels of kind of irony and self-knowledge um but it is it does feel now like you know that couldn't have happened in 2005
是的，我的意思是，消除距离，我想。伦敦，举个例子，再次说明，这也许是一种非常“以英格兰为中心”的思考方式，但20世纪90年代初的伦敦感觉是一个与今天非常不同的城市，少了很多多元文化，少了很多国际化，我会这么说。我认为像技术、国际旅行以及那种瞬息万变的感觉和充满可能性的感觉，现在比90年代要宏大得多。我的意思是，我不知道。我不是伦敦人。我记得甚至去伦敦时，你知道的，还得带上一张地图以及所有这些行头。那种将世界装在口袋里、体现在智能手机中的感觉在当时是完全不存在的。我想那是去年还是前年，
because by that point the charts had already fallen from you know from national prominence it was no longer part of the story um the other moment i think which is a shared national moment for british listeners which everyone will remember is the death of princess diana but maybe we should take a break first and then get into that um you know it's such a big topic um yes okay okay we'll come back after the break and we will talk death of diana i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes
是一档关于杰里米·代勒（Jeremy Deller）这位伟大艺术家的节目，是的，他拍摄了一系列关于锐舞文化（rave culture）的影片，
and early access to live tickets head to the rest of entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History, and a reminder that we're operating on double shifts at the moment during lockdown, so two episodes a week. And on Thursday, we have a rather more salacious offering, as Tom and I are joined by Hallie Rubenhold to talk about sex in the 18th and 19th centuries. Very not safe for work, that one, at least I hope. Now that Tom's wiped the steam from his glasses, we can get back to the 1990s.
以及在英格兰各地行驶的车队，并把它放给伦敦的一群小学生看。他们所有人在观看时都完全无法理解。对他们来说，那是一个完全陌生的世界。部分原因是因为代勒展示的影片中的每个人都是白人。而伦敦教室里的情况并非如此。那是自90年代以来发生的人口结构变化的一种迹象，我想。所以这也是发生的事情的另一个方面。
So Tom, we were going to talk about the death of Diana. Do you remember the death of... It's one of those moments, isn't it, where you remember where you were and what you were doing? I do. I remember it very well because we were moving house. Right. And we wanted some kind of cheery music to you know peppers up as we were shoveling chairs and things and kind of in the wind just wall-to-wall somber funerary music um yeah the whole thing was yes very peculiar and do you think the kind of thing that would i mean again like like the the blow is a shared moment i suppose it probably would wouldn't it actually but it would be kind of bubbles of shared
说到这一点，马修·马瑟（Matthew Mather），我不知道该怎么发音，我向他或她道歉。为什么现在与1990年之间的文化差距没有感觉像1960年到1990年之间那么大？是因为冷战吗？还是只有我这么觉得？这位作者出生于90年代。我的意思是，这是一个非常有趣、真正有趣的点，你会把它推到19世纪——甚至可能是1997年，也许伴随着……我的意思是，我猜文化差距——现在和20世纪90年代之间感觉有文化差距吗？没有巨大的文化差距，对吧？
experience in a way that yes i mean imagine the tweets and imagine the yes i mean i think the death of diana is such a sort of relief of maficking kind of moment i mean british britain specializes in these sort of outpourings of Dickensian sentimentality, doesn't it? So did you do anything that you now feel embarrassed about? Do you know what? I was actually, I was in Bulgaria. I was backpacking in Bulgaria and a man at our youth hostel told us that Prince Stenner died. We watched it on TV. And then, extraordinary thing, we were in this tiny village in the Balkan mountains.
这种体验就像是，是的，我的意思是想象一下那些推特，想象一下，是的，我的意思是，我认为戴安娜的去世就像是一种宣泄般的情感宣泄时刻，我的意思是，英国人非常擅长这种狄更斯式的感伤宣泄，不是吗？所以你有没有做过什么现在觉得尴尬的事？你知道吗？我其实当时在保加利亚。我在保加利亚背包旅行，我们青年旅舍的一个男人告诉我们说斯坦纳王子去世了。我们在电视上看到了。然后，不可思议的是，我们在巴尔干山脉的一个小村庄里。
And people in the village all got out these wooden chairs from their houses. And they all gathered in the center in this square in front of this battered old kind of communist era telly. And they were all watching something on the telly. And we were backpackers, so we didn't. You know, this is pre-internet. And they were watching the funeral they were watching elton john and george carey and john major and tony blair uh in english and they were it was absolutely bizarre and i remember thinking at the time why who do they really care and they did so it was an international event oh it clearly was in the mountains of bul. Yeah. So I think it was actually. I think, obviously, would that happen now? Does the British royalty have this?
村里的人都从家里搬出了木椅。他们都聚集在巴尔干山脉那个破旧的共产主义时代电视机前的广场中央。他们都在看电视上的东西。我们是背包客，所以没有。你知道，这是互联网普及之前。他们正在看葬礼，他们在看埃尔顿·约翰、乔治·凯利、约翰·梅杰和托尼·布莱尔用英语播报，他们当时真的觉得非常诡异，我记得当时想，为什么，他们为什么真的在乎？但他们的确在乎，所以这是一场国际事件，哦，它显然是在保加利亚的山里。是的。所以我想它确实是。我想，显而易见，如果现在发生这种事会怎样？英国王室还有这种影响力吗？
I mean, probably it does because of the crown. Yeah, maybe. Well, I mean, on the topic of people actually gathering around a television, I mean, how retro is that? Comment from P. O'Connell. I look back now to my own life in the 90s he says and i think it would have been entirely different with access to a smartphone so that kind of follows up really what we're talking about that technology yeah perhaps is the greatest agent of transformation
我的意思是，可能因为《王冠》这部剧它还是有的吧。是的，也许吧。好吧，我的意思是，说到人们真正围坐在电视机旁，这有多复古啊？来自 P. O'Connell 的评论。他说，回首我在90年代的生活，我想如果当时能用上智能手机，一切都会完全不同，所以这实际上延续了我们刚才谈论的话题，即技术，是的，也许它是最具变革性的力量。
of anything yes i mean the elimination of distance i suppose suppose. London, for example, again, this is a very sort of Anglo-Central way to think of it maybe, but London in the early 1990s feels like a very different city from what it is today, much less multicultural, much less international, I would say. And I think things like technology and international travel and the sort of sense of, just the sense of flux and the sense of possibility is so much greater now than it was in the 90s. I mean, I don't know. I wasn't from London. And I remember even going to London, you know, having to get a map and all this kind of carry on. That sort of sense of having the world in your pocket embodied in your smartphone was utterly absent. I think it was last, maybe last year the year before um and it was um a program about jeremy della the great artist yeah um taking a series of films about kind of rave culture and
无论什么方面，是的，我的意思是消除距离感，我想。例如伦敦，再次强调，这可能是一种非常以英国为中心的思考方式，但20世纪90年代初的伦敦感觉与今天非常不同，可以说，多元文化少得多，国际化也少得多。我认为像技术、国际旅行以及那种瞬息万变的感觉、充满可能性的感觉，现在比90年代要强烈得多。我的意思是，我不知道。我不是伦敦人。我还记得去伦敦时不得不带地图之类的繁琐事。那种将世界装进口袋、体现在智能手机里的感觉在当时是完全不存在的。我想是去年，也许是前两年，嗯，这是一个关于伟大的艺术家杰里米·德勒的节目，是的，嗯，他拍摄了一系列关于锐舞文化的电影，还有
about the convoys going around england uh and showing it to a class of schoolchildren in London. And all of them watching it in absolute incomprehension. It was a completely alien world to them. Partly because everybody in the films that Della was showing were white. Whereas that wasn't the case in the classroom in London. And that was a kind of indication of the kind of demographic change, I guess, that has happened since the 90s. So that is another aspect of what's happened.
关于在英国各地巡游的车队，嗯，并把它放给伦敦的一群小学生看。他们所有人都一脸茫然地看着，完全无法理解。对他们来说，那是一个完全陌生的世界。部分原因是因为德勒展示的电影中的每个人都是白人。而伦敦的教室里却并非如此。我想这正是自90年代以来发生的人口结构变化的一种体现。所以这也是所发生的事情的另一个方面。
On which point, Mac Matthew Mather, I don't know how you pronounce that, I apologise to him or her. Why does the cultural gap between now and 1990 not feel as great as that of 1960 to 1990 is it the cold war is it just me the author born in the 90s i mean i think that is an interesting really interesting point and you would push it kind of to the 19 maybe even 97 with perhaps um i mean the cultural gap i suppose i mean does it feel like there's a cultural gap between now and the 1990s? Not a massive cultural gap, is there?
说到这一点，麦克·马修·马瑟（我不知道该怎么发音，向他或她道歉）。为什么现在与1990年之间的文化鸿沟感觉没有1960年到1990年之间那么大？是因为冷战吗？还是只有我一个人这么觉得？这位作者出生于90年代，我的意思是，我认为这是一个非常有趣、真正有趣的点，你可以把它推到19年代，甚至可能到97年，也许，嗯，我的意思是文化鸿沟，我想，我的意思是，现在和1990年代之间真的有文化鸿沟吗？没有巨大的文化鸿沟，对吧？
I mean, whereas you're right, Mac or he or she is absolutely right that the gap between 1960 and 1993 feels colossal. And I guess it felt colossal at the time, didn't it? Which sort of just explodes the entire thesis of my series of books, which is that nothing changed in the entire thesis of my series of books which is that um nothing changed in the 60s and 70s but of course something did i guess something did change particularly in the i think 70s and 80s as um social change accelerated but you're right i mean we are you can do all these sort of we are you know the sex pistols are closer to
我的意思是，虽然你说得对，麦克（或者他/她）绝对认为1960年到1993年之间的鸿沟感觉极其巨大。而且我想当时大家也觉得鸿沟巨大，对吧？这简直颠覆了我整套系列书籍的核心论点——即我在书里认为上世纪60和70年代什么都没有改变。但当然，有些事情确实变了，我想确实有些事情变了，特别是在我认为的70和80年代，随着……社会变迁加速。不过你说的对，我的意思是，我们……你可以做所有这些类似……我们，你知道的，性手枪乐队距离
george formby than they are to us or something. You can do all these sort of little quirks to show how periods and some periods in history are closer together or further apart than you think. And the 1990s do feel quite close to us in a way that they didn't feel close to the 50s or to the 60s. I mean, I suppose the two massive, massive changes between 1990 and, so the world before 1990 and the world after 1990 is the technological one and the end of the Cold War. So the end of the Cold War completely recalibrates the geopolitical circumstances. Yeah. It transfigures the way in which people understand how the world relates.
乔治·福姆比的距离，比距离我们还要近，诸如此类。你可以用这些小怪癖来证明，历史上的某些时期比你想象的要更接近或更疏远。而20世纪90年代对我们来说确实感觉相当近，这是50年代或60年代所没有的那种亲近感。我的意思是，我想1990年与——也就是说1990年以前的世界和1990年以后的世界——这两个巨大无比的变化，一个是技术变革，另一个是冷战结束。因此，冷战的结束彻底重新校准了地平缘政治环境。是的。它改变了人们理解世界相互联系的方式。
It opens the door for the rise of China. It affects the evolution of the European Union. It changes, you know, America becomes a kind of hyperpower and then kind of plummets. So all these kind of changes are implicit in that, but they're recognizably bred of the kind of the collapse of the Cold War. Although that's a very anomalous moment, Tom. I think that's a very anomalous moment, the collapse of the the cold war because actually the world we're in now is arguably more similar
它为中国的崛起打开了大门，影响了欧盟的发展，改变了……你知道的，美国变成了一种超级大国，然后又某种程度上急剧衰落。所以所有这些变革都隐含其中，但它们显然是冷战崩溃所孕育出来的产物。尽管那是一个非常反常的时刻，汤姆。我认为冷战的崩溃是一个非常反常的时刻，因为事实上我们现在身处的这个世界，从地缘政治角度来看，可以说是更加相似
to the pre-1990 world geopolitically than to the so you've got two powers now um america's no longer a hyper power they've changed yeah they've changed china has eclipsed russia i mean but russia and so for europeans we're no longer central in the cold Cold War, we were the battleground. I mean, it wasn't a very pleasant position to be, but we mattered. Whereas now it's America and China and Europe's a bit of a backwater. So that is a kind of sobering change. Yes, although Europe probably mattered. Well, it was, as you say, a battleground. I mean, we're a battleground over which others fought rather than a one with a great deal of agency in ourselves i mean that's one reason why people wanted to set up the european union in the first place was they felt that britain that europe had become europe they didn't
与1990年之前的世界相比，现在的世界更接近……所以你现在有两个大国……嗯，美国不再是超级大国了，它们变了，是的，它们变了，中国已经超越了俄罗斯——我的意思是，但是俄罗斯……因此对欧洲人来说，我们在冷战中不再处于中心地位，我们曾是战场。我的意思是，这并不是一个令人愉快的处境，但我们很重要。而现在是美国和中国，欧洲有点像个死水潭。所以这是一个令人清醒的改变。是的，尽管欧洲可能曾经很重要。嗯，正如你所说，它是一个战场。我的意思是，我们是一个被他人争夺的战场，而不是一个自身拥有很大自主权的战场——我的意思是，这也是人们当初想要建立欧盟的原因之一，他们觉得英国……欧洲已经变成了欧洲，他们不想
want to just be this sort of passive arena over which rival superpowers fought but that's kind of our europe's position now i think it's a sort of slightly passive arena i mean when you know the europe is no not necessarily weaker now than it was in the 50s and 60s because i don't think it was actually particularly strong about them anyway anyway well whatever and then uh technology so we which we've already discussed but that really is a kind of huge change yeah nicholas rogers says was it was the 90s a time when things felt just right, technology exciting rather than a ubiquitous grind, loads of originality and culture, sensible politics, end of the Cold War? Well, we've sort of alluded to this. I mean, you can tell that story and say, yes, technology was terribly exciting.
只是成为一个被敌对超级大国争夺的被动竞技场，但这就是我们欧洲现在的地位，我觉得它有点像一个稍微被动的竞技场。我的意思是，当你知道欧洲现在并不一定比50和60年代更弱时，因为我觉得它当时其实也不是特别强大……不管怎样，好吧……然后是技术，我们之前已经讨论过了，但这确实是一个巨大的改变。是的，尼古拉斯·罗杰斯问：90年代是一个让事情感觉恰到好处的时期吗？技术令人兴奋，而不是无处不在的枯燥乏味，文化上有大量的独创性，理智的政治，冷战的结束？嗯，我们之前已经提到过这一点。我的意思是，你可以讲述那样一个故事，并说，是的，技术极其令人兴奋。
Yes, everything felt right and rosy. But you can equally tell that story and say, actually, it's not the seeds of future problems were sowed in the 1990s and you couldn't have... You know, sometimes people say of a particular period, well, is that when things went wrong, when we got things wrong? But the idea that we could get things right and fix it is an illusion.
是的，一切都感觉正确而美好。但你同样可以讲述另一个故事，并说，事实上，并非如此——未来问题的种子正是在20世纪90年代播下的，而你不可能……你知道的，有时人们会针对某个特定时期说，嗯，那是事情出错的时候吗？是我们把事情搞砸的时候吗？但那种认为我们可以把事情做好并解决它的想法只是一种错觉。
Things were always going to go wrong because that's the nature of history. Well, on which topic again, question from William Ritchie. is it reasonable to see blair and 97 as the resolution of the uk's 20th century the end of hereditary peers hong kong return devolution good friday agreement or was it papering over the cracks papering over the cracks um i wouldn't go with papering over the cracks because i think that's sort of that the implication of that question is there are deep problems that then became apparent.
事情总是会出问题，因为这就是历史的本质。好吧，说到这个话题，威廉·里奇（William Ritchie）又提出了一个问题：把布莱尔和1997年视为英国20世纪的结局、世袭贵族的终结、香港回归、权力下放、耶稣受难日协议，是否合理？还是说这只是粉饰太平？粉饰太平……嗯，我不会用“粉饰太平”这个词，因为我认为那个问题的隐含意思是，随后显现出了深刻的问题。
But I mean, all societies have problems. That's the nature of being a society. I think I think clearly the Blair government was able to resolve things, partly because a lot of the heavy lifting. I mean, I would argue had been sort of done already in a lot of sort of economic battles seem to be settled. So they could then put their energies into Northern Ireland and all this sort of done already and a lot of sort of economic battles seem to be settled so they could then put their energies into northern ireland and all this sort of stuff um but were they papering over the cracks i mean i don't believe the uk is actually more cracked than other nations do you tom um well i i i loved blair that's a great that's a great admission i know i i was so happy uh when he was elected and i i'm sure you know the there was a kind of feeling that politics wasn't something to worry about and everything was going great and i just kind of put put my um my kind of uh political gear stick
但我的意思是，所有社会都有问题。这就是作为一个社会的本质。我认为，显然布莱尔政府能够解决问题，部分原因在于很多重活……我的意思是，我认为可以说是已经做得差不多了，很多经济上的斗争似乎已经解决。所以他们可以把精力投入到北爱尔兰和所有这些事情上……已经做完了，很多经济上的斗争似乎已经解决，所以他们可以把精力投入到北爱尔兰和所有这些事情上……嗯，但他们是在粉饰太平吗？我的意思是，我不相信英国实际上比其他国家裂痕更多，你是吗，汤姆？嗯……我……我曾深爱布莱尔，这是一个伟大的承认。我知道，我太高兴了……当他当选时，我确信你知道，当时有一种感觉，即政治并不是一件需要担心的事情，一切都进展顺利，我只是把我那种……我那种……政治换挡杆
into neutral and coasted along and thought about other things. But of course, all kinds of things were creeping up through the undergrowth. Isn't it an interesting thing with Blair, though, Tom, that, you know, he left office in 2007 and people applauded him out of the House of Commons. He had a standing ovation from both sides of the House. I can still see David Cameron kind of encouraging all his Tory MPs to stand and applaud Blair. Blair left at the height of his powers. And now it is Blair who sort of struggles to show his face in public because people will shout at him. Whereas John Major, his much lampooned predecessor, if people see John Major
挂入空挡，然后一路滑行，去想别的事情了。但是，当然，各种各样的事情都在杂草丛生中悄悄蔓延。汤姆，关于布莱尔，难道不是一件很有趣的事情吗？你知道，他在2007年卸任，人们为他离开下议院鼓掌。议会两党都起立为他鼓掌。我还能看到大卫·卡梅伦鼓励他所有的保守党议员起立为布莱尔鼓掌。布莱尔在权力巅峰时离职。而现在，反而是布莱尔在公众面前羞于露面，因为人们会对他大喊大叫。相比之下，约翰·梅杰——他那位饱受讽刺的前任，如果人们在大街上看到约翰·梅杰
in the street, they say, oh, it's John Major, nice to see him. He wasn't so bad, you know. Isn't that extraordinary, the reversal in fortunes? Except people never hated Major, did they? No, they didn't. There was the sense of division. You never had that. No.
，他们会说：“哦，那是约翰·梅杰，很高兴见到他。他其实没那么糟，你知道的。”这难道不非同寻常吗，命运的逆转？除非人们从未讨厌过梅杰，对吧？不，他们没有。那种分裂感是从未有过的。你从来没有过那种感觉。不。
I mean, people kind of mildly contemptuous of him. He would cut his shirt into his underpants and cone hotlines and things. Yeah. But nobody hated him. No, not at all. And actually, the great thing for him is that the more that Tony Blair has sort of remained in the public eye, the more John Major's stock has risen. So they're sort of yoked together. Well, yeah, I feel like kind of Odysseus listening to the sirens.
我的意思是，人们对他的态度有点轻微的蔑视。他会把衬衫塞进内裤里，拨打热线电话之类的事情。是的。但没有人恨他。不，一点也没有。事实上，对约翰·梅杰来说最棒的事情是，托尼·布莱尔在公众视野中露面越多，约翰·梅杰的声望就越高。所以他们俩就像是被绑在了一起。好吧，是的，我感觉自己就像是听着海妖歌声的奥德修斯。
I know it's bad, but whenever I hear Tony Blair, I always go, yeah, he's so right. Yes, absolutely. You need to be chained to the mast. Stuartie Mook, great name. Yeah. What effect has the 90s drug culture had on today? Now, Dominic, I know you're a great one for saying that drug culture
我知道这不好，但每当我听到托尼·布莱尔说话，我总是会想：“对啊，他说得太对了。”是的，绝对的。你需要把自己绑在桅杆上。斯图尔蒂·穆克（Stuartie Mook），好名字。是的。90年代的毒品文化对今天产生了什么影响？好了，多米尼克，我知道你一直擅长说毒品文化
has had no effect on anything. Well, I think people had a slightly different attitude to drugs in the 90s, didn't they? The 90s, I would say, felt a little little bit like a certainly among people of sort of our generation that drugs were they were you know purely recreational cool um almost harmless actually that was the sort of assumption i think among people in their 20s and i don't think people talked about drugs with with the i mean think people talked about drugs with the, I mean, now people talk about drugs with much greater,
对任何事情都没有影响。嗯，我觉得90年代人们对毒品的态度有点不同，不是吗？我会说，90年代感觉有点……至少在我们这一代人当中，毒品是……你知道的，纯粹是消遣、很酷……甚至几乎是无害的。我想这大概是20世纪20多岁年轻人心中的假设，而且我不认为人们在谈论毒品时带有……我的意思是，我认为人们在谈论毒品时……我的意思是，现在人们谈论毒品时，
I would say, foreboding than the, though it'd be interesting to compare that then with the stats and to see how popular they are and also how the class base has changed with drugs. I mean, I think the way in which suddenly you had football hooligans hugging each other on the floor of the Hacienda and all that kind of thing. As a kind of folk myth, it's up there with the Summer of Love of 1967. Yeah.
我会说，比当时带有更多的不祥预感，尽管把当时的情况与统计数据进行对比，看看它们的受欢迎程度，以及毒品的阶级基础是如何变化的，这会很有趣。我的意思是，我认为那种突然之间你会看到足球流氓在哈西安达俱乐部的舞池地板上互相拥抱的现象，诸如此类。作为一种民间神话，它完全可以与1967年的“爱之夏”相提并论。是的。
That it, as a myth, perhaps, it continues to have an impact, I think. Because I think the whole idea of the XC culture, you know, we can all just love one another. And so many people did experience that, even if it was kind of chemically induced, that actually all you need is love. And I think that people of our generation still bear the stamp of that, I think. I think that there is a kind of slight, why can't we all just love each other and be friends, that ironically breeds all kinds of vituperation and kind of moral righteousness.
作为一个神话，也许它仍在产生影响，我认为。因为我认为整个锐舞文化（XC culture）的理念，你知道，我们都可以彼此相爱。而且那么多人确实经历了这一点，即使它是化学物质诱导的，但实际上你所需要的只有爱。而且我认为我们这一代人身上仍然带有那种印记，我想。我认为有一种轻微的……为什么我们不能都彼此相爱、做朋友呢？这具有讽刺意味地滋生了各种各样的恶毒攻击和某种道德优越感。
But I think, you know, be kind is, I mean, it's always a terrifying, menacing kind of thing when you see it on a Twitter thread or something. Why can't people just be kind? When people say that, they mean it in the most, they mean it in the most vitriolic way, usually. Yes, but I think the ideal of kindness, of love, of everyone just hugging each other and not kicking each other in or whatever,
但我想，你知道，“保持善良”——我的意思是，当你在推特话题之类的上面看到这句话时，它总是有一种可怕的、来势汹汹的感觉。为什么人们就不能善良一点呢？当人们这么说的时候，他们通常是用最恶毒的方式说出来的。是的，但善良的理想、爱的理想、每个人都只是互相拥抱而不是把对方踢倒在地之类的理想，
as a myth, it does kind of have a kind of enduring resonance. Maybe not, I don't know. My son does something at school that he refers to as kindness studies. And it's surely only a matter of time before that becomes a degree anyway um that's all the influence of of rave culture okay this is a great question from nicholas again i hope i've pronounced this right juan juan juan um were the 1990s the last decade of uncritical americanism on screen and indeed perhaps beyond screen films like independence like Independence Day, The Patriot, Armageddon, or even Saving Private Ryan seem unthinkable
作为一个神话，它确实具有某种持久的共鸣。也许没有吧，我不知道。我儿子在学校里上了一门他称之为“善良研究”的课程。这肯定只是时间问题，它迟早会变成一个学位。不管怎样……这就是锐舞文化的所有影响。好吧，这是尼古拉斯提出的一个很好的问题，我希望我发音没出错，胡安·胡安·胡安（Juan Juan Juan）……20世纪90年代是银幕上（甚至可能超越银幕）最后十年的无批判美国主义吗？诸如《独立日》、《爱国者》、《世界末日》甚至《拯救大兵瑞恩》之类的电影，在它们今天描绘美国的方式上，
in the way they picture the US nowadays. I totally agree with that. That's just a really good observation. I think that is true. I think there was a... America, you know, it had its issues, but clearly there was a sense that Hollywood projected that they had, in inverted commas, won the Cold War.
简直是不可想象的。我完全同意这一点。这真是一个非常好的观察。我认为这是真的。我认为曾经有一种……美国，你知道，它有自己的问题，但很明显有一种感觉，即好莱坞投射出的形象是，他们加引号地赢得了冷战。
It was always presented that way. It wasn't presented as a matter of Gorbachev's reforms going wrong and the Soviet Union falling apart. And there was this quite uncritical sense. I saw Saving Private Ryan in a cinema in America, and I can remember the scene. They've got a colossal American flag flying at one point, the shot is of this American flag. And, I mean, there were people sobbing in the auditorium around me. And I just sat there.
它总是被这样呈现。它并没有被呈现为戈尔巴乔夫的改革出错以及苏联解体的问题。而且当时存在一种相当无批判的感觉。我曾在美国的一家电影院看过《拯救大兵瑞恩》，我还记得那个场景。他们当时挂着一面巨大无比的美国国旗，镜头特写了这面美国国旗。而且，我的意思是，我周围礼堂里的人都在啜泣。而我只是坐在那里。
I've never felt so British in my life. Just this. I just wanted to leave. I just wanted to leave the cinema, to be honest. I'm just so churlish and nasty as a person. Well, the Saving Private Ryan famously featured the British war effort, didn't it? Yeah, well, of course.
我一生中从未感到自己如此英国。就是这种感觉。我只想离开。说实话，我当时只想离开电影院。我这个人就是这么乖戾和讨厌。嗯，《拯救大兵瑞恩》里著名的镜头展现了英国的战争努力，不是吗？是的，嗯，当然。
I think, yes. And I think that's actually a really interesting story. The last few years is the collapse of America as this sort of idealistic model. In their own minds, actually, as well as in ours. You know, you see American politicians breastfeeding about the fact that they're being mocked elsewhere in the world or they're being seen as a sort of a model of what to avoid. And I think that would have been unthinkable back in the 1990s well i mean it's interesting that both of us talking about you know remembering how we got connected to the internet both of us have a link to stanford both of us had american
我想，是的。而且我认为这其实是一个非常有趣的故事。过去几年的情况是，美国作为这种理想主义模范的崩溃。不仅在我们的心中，其实在他们自己的心中也是如此。你知道，你会看到美国政客们为自己遭到世界其他地方的嘲笑或被视为反面教材而感到气急败坏。我想这在20世纪90年代是不可想象的。嗯，我的意思是，有趣的是，我们俩都在谈论……你知道的，回忆我们是如何连上互联网的，我们俩都与斯坦福大学有联系，我们俩都有美国
friends who helped to set it up i mean but essentially we we felt like kind of primitives absolutely america was america was was the future whereas now i think you go to america often it's it certainly in terms of its infrastructure and even in terms of the phones and things, it seems... Yeah, I completely agree, Tom. I totally agree. I think that's a bit... I first went to America in the 90s and was struck by the modernity of it. I mean, they had things that we didn't have.
朋友帮助建立它。我的意思是，但本质上我们觉得自己就像某种原始人。绝对的，美国就是……美国就是未来。然而现在，我觉得你去美国，通常……至少在基础设施方面，甚至在手机之类的方面，它似乎……是的，我完全同意，汤姆。我完全同意。我觉得有点……我第一次去美国是在90年代，被它的现代感震撼了。我的意思是，他们有我们没有的东西。
And even just tiny, piffling little things that were somehow symbolic so i can remember going and they're having films that i had that had not come out in europe but i'd never even heard of you know they're because their film schedule was always ahead of ours yeah um yeah and then going back home and saying to people oh there's a new arnold schwarzenegger film or whatever you won't have heard of it but but I've seen it in America. And that sense of them literally being ahead, technologically, culturally, that has gone, hasn't it? The internet has destroyed that,
甚至只是一些微不足道的、某种程度上具有象征意义的小事。所以我记得我去过那里，看到了在欧洲尚未上映、甚至我从未听说过的电影，你知道的，因为他们的电影档期总是比我们超前。是的……嗯，是的，然后回到家对人们说：“哦，有一部新的阿诺·施瓦辛格电影什么的，你可能没听说过，但我在美国看过。”那种他们确实在技术上、文化上领先的感觉已经消失了，不是吗？互联网摧毁了这一点，
but also there's a sense that America has failed to kick on after 1989, 1990. Also, I think my favourite series of the 90s was The X-Files, which I loved because it was kind of engagingly paranoid. You could watch it and enjoy it and it was clearly nonsense. But the kind of the vague hint that perhaps there were aliens in Roswell or whatever. Whereas now all of that has become completely terrifying. I mean, essentially, The X-Files has become QAnon and it's not fun. It's not fun at all.
但同时也有这样一种感觉：美国未能从1989年、1990年的辉煌中继续前进。另外，我想我90年代最喜欢的电视剧是《X档案》，我很喜欢它，因为它有一种引人入胜的偏执感。你可以看着它，觉得很有趣，而且它显然是胡扯。但那种隐约的暗示——也许罗斯韦尔真的有外星人什么的。而现在，所有这些都变得完全可怕了。我的意思是，本质上，《X档案》已经变成了匿名者Q（QAnon），一点也不好玩。一点也不好玩。
On the topic of weird stuff that people believe, a question from Steve HP, wonderful man. The history of the 1990s was affected in important ways by Pope St. John Paul II, the Islamic Republic of Iran, Osama bin Laden, the destruction of the Aja Mosque and the soft power of the Dalai Lama. Are Western historians, you, Dominic, equipped with a conceptual framework to explain this? I've got a great conceptual framework. Actually, you don't need to worry about my conceptual framework, Tom. So this is, I guess, I'm guessing a question about religion, really. It's a question about...
说到人们相信的古怪事情，斯蒂芬·HP（Steve HP）这位了不起的人提出了一个问题：20世纪90年代的历史在重要方面受到了教宗圣若望·保罗二世、伊朗伊斯兰共和国、奥萨马·本·拉登、巴布里清真寺的拆除以及达赖喇嘛的软实力的影响。西方历史学家——比如你，多米尼克——是否具备了解释这一切的概念框架？我有一个极好的概念框架。实际上，你不需要担心我的概念框架，汤姆。所以我想这是一个关于宗教的问题，真的。这是一个关于……
Yes, I think it's... And specifically institutional religion. So not the kind of alien X-Files kind of spiritual, but not religious stuff that you get in the 90s, but organised. So it's an interesting thing, isn't it? Because the 1990s felt like a kind of death of God period. The sort of Fukuyama book and the idea that sort of humanistic
是的，我认为是……具体来说是体制化的宗教。所以不是90年代那种外星人、《X档案》式的精神层面但非宗教的东西，而是有组织的宗教。所以这是一个有趣的问题，对吧？因为20世纪90年代感觉像是一个“上帝之死”的时期。弗山（Fukuyama）的书以及那种认为人文主义
liberal democracy was the future. And that I definitely remember sort of putting my purely sort of personal memory hat back on. The way that people talked about iran and the ayatollah and the rushd fatwa and whatnot that these were relics these were soon to be forgotten kind of relics people would often say it's medieval sort of behavior and they talk about iran as a medieval regime and people did that a lot actually after 9 11 as well and it's clear now that people particularly in the sort of secular west underestimated the resilience of religion
自由民主就是未来的观点。我绝对记得重新戴上我纯粹个人记忆的帽子。人们谈论伊朗、阿亚图拉、拉什迪教令等事情的方式，认为这些都是遗迹，是很快会被遗忘的遗迹，人们经常说这是中世纪的行为，他们把伊朗称为中世纪政权，9/11之后人们也经常这样说。现在很明显，人们——特别是世俗西方世界的人——低估了宗教的韧性，
and the way in which religious identity and religious loyalty would play a part particularly in the post-cold war world and i actually hate this question because it's such a gift to you it is um because i i had i had no interest in this question at all in the 90s. I mean, it was nothing to me. I barely read it on my radar. Whereas now, of course, I have realised that that was completely wrong. And I've written a book about it called Dominion, which is available from all good bookshops.
以及宗教认同和宗教忠诚在后冷战世界中将要发挥的作用。其实我讨厌这个问题，因为它对你来说太像是一份大礼了。是的……因为我在90年代对这个问题完全不感兴趣。我的意思是，它对我来说什么都不是，甚至几乎没进入我的雷达范围。然而现在，我当然意识到那是完全错误的。我还为此写了一本书，书名叫《多米尼克》（Dominion），各大好书店均有售。
And on that... Shame on us. On that... good bookshops and on that shameless on that I only agreed to this topic because I could see that that question would come up I think we should draw a line I don't see how we can top that okay well I think you should give me one is the one moment from the
关于这一点……真丢脸。关于这一点……好书店，还有关于这种厚颜无耻的行为……我之所以同意这个话题，是因为我看出那个问题会出现。我认为我们应该划清界限，我不知道我们怎么能超越这一点。好吧，那我认为你应该给我一个……你认为我们不该谈论、但我们应该更多谈论的90年代的某个时刻是什么？你认为历史学家不会谈论、但我们应该更多谈论的是什么？有什么意想不到的事情吗？你不能问我这个问题。在经历了不管什么事情之后，我觉得太累了。但显然你确实有答案，所以告诉我，那个时刻是什么？你显然对这个问题有答案。
1990s that you think we don't talk about that we should talk about more that you think historians will't talk about that we should talk about more that you think historians will look at is there anything unexpected you can't ask me that question i i i feel too tired after great whatever it is but clearly you do so tell me what is the moment what you clearly have an answer to this question um i think actually probably britain not joining the euro from a british oh very good yes very good um i think not joining the euro was so we did brexit before and uh i think we've both we've both read the book by robert toombs about um he's a big brexiteer professor robert toombs about brexit he makes the argument that brexit would not have been possible had we joined the
嗯，我认为实际上可能是英国没有加入欧元区，从英国的视角来看……哦，非常好，是的，非常好。嗯，我认为没有加入欧元区意味着我们在脱欧之前就已经……而且我们俩都读过罗伯特·图姆斯（Robert Tombs）关于……他是一位坚定的脱欧派教授，罗伯特·图姆斯关于脱欧的书，他提出了这样一个论点：如果我们加入了欧元区，脱欧将是不可能的。
euro i think he's right because the economic damage of crushing out of the euro would just be so great and that was actually gordon i mean that will probably go down as gordon brown's apart from as he would himself put it saving the world in 2008 after the crash gordon brown's great contribution to british history i mean great as in as in important rather than as a term of approval uh by not joining the Euro, that made Brexit possible in a way that... Or would you say inevitable? Well, Tumors would say inevitable. But that's a massive question. It was Brexit, inevitable.
我认为他是对的，因为硬着陆退出欧元区的经济代价实在太大了。这实际上是戈登……我的用词是——正如他自己所说，除了在2008年金融危机后拯救世界之外——戈登·布莱尔……哦不，是戈登·布朗对英国历史的巨大贡献。我的意思是“巨大”是指重要，而不是赞许的词汇——通过没有加入欧元区，这使得脱欧成为可能，某种程度上……或者你会说是不可避免的？嗯，图姆斯会说是不可避免的。但这可是一个巨大的问题：脱欧是不可避免的吗？
Surely there's a podcast in that. Yes, we must get Helen Thompson. Yeah. She's brilliant on this topic. We're now sharing our backstage conversations with the audience and we should stop. Yes, so I think that's it. I think we declare the 90s over.
这里面肯定能做一个播客。是的，我们必须请来海伦·汤普森（Helen Thompson）。是的。她在这一话题上非常出色。我们现在正和听众分享我们的后台对话，我们应该停下来了。是的，所以就是这样。我认为我们应该宣布90年代结束了。
Please join us next time as we head back and take a good look at sex in the 18th and 19th centuries. Goodbye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请下次继续收听我们回溯并仔细审视18和19世纪性爱史的节目。再见。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。